[Music]
lake turkana in kenya
home to the biggest wind farm in africa
its 365 turbines produce
enough energy to power one million homes
and offset some seven hundred
thousand tons of carbon per year along
with investment from private businesses
the project was able to get off the
ground with the partnership of the
european union
just like europe the african continent
is facing significant challenges for the
future
from decarbonizing its economy to the
digital transformation
promoting good governance to migration
the european parliament thinks that by
working together
both the eu and africa will be stronger
la priorite se le development
parliament believes that these
challenges present both continents with
opportunities
european companies and africa's rapidly
growing markets will both benefit from
european private investment
meps say a new partnership addressing
healthcare education
and teacher training and the empowerment
of girls and women
should be a priority
the autonomization of
meps want the eu africa strategy to go
further than just cooperation
and build a lasting mutually beneficial
relationship
the future strategy should help support
projects which boost climate adaptation
like the turkana wind farm
support the creation of africa's
continental free trade area
and help reduce the continent's
dependence on imports
[Music]